That's what hope is.
That's what hope is,...
...imagining and then fighting for and then working for what did not seem possible before.
That's leadership.
John F. Kennedy didn't look up at the moon and say, "That's too far."
"We can't go, false hopes."
Martin Luther King didn't stand on the steps of the Lincoln Memorial and say,...
..."Go home everybody, the dream's deferred, false hopes."
"You all need a reality check."
There is a moment in the life of every generation...
...when that spirit of hopefulness has to come through if we are to make our mark on history.
When we cast aside the fear and the doubt and the cynicism...
...and we stop settling for what the cynics tell us we have to settle for.
When we join together and we decide...
...that we are gonna roll up our sleeves and we are gonna remake this country block by block,...
...neighborhood by neighborhood,...
...county by county,...
...state by state.
When we decide in our guts, when we are determined...
...that our children and grandchildren deserve the same chance that somebody gave us.
When we make a determination and we are willing to fight on the basis of the conviction...
...that we are gonna keep the dream alive for those who still yearn for justice...
...and still thirst for opportunity.